okay.
I am going to start with program today doing
something that number one doesn't happen very
often on the show.
And
number two is not something that I think most
of our viewers and listeners would expect
at this point.
I'm going to praise Donald Trump because he
did, uh, did something that I agree with.
This doesn't happen often, but when it does,
I tell you right away partially because it's
so notable.
You know, those ads that you see on television
for medications, the do you feel tired in
the morning?
Well, if so you might be suffering from x
and y and here's a pill that might help you
with that and here's 30 side effects up to
and including death that uh, you might suffer
from if you decide to take this pill.
Those are the ads that starting as soon as
this summer, big Pharma will be required to
actually state the price of medications that
they are advertising in their commercials
for Donald Trump announced this week.
This is going to apply specifically to any
drug.
We're a monthly supply costs more than 35
bucks.
We're all very used to hearing the side effect
list of side effects that the drug might cause.
It's usually super sped up narration in the
last like five seconds of the ad.
That's because of a government regulation
which said you must list the possible side
effects.
Uh, in these commercials.
This is going to be a similar provision where
the price of the drug will have to be included
in those advertisements.
This is a good thing.
Good for Donald Trump for doing it.
This is now like the second thing that Trump
has done that I can remember that I agree
with the first being, uh, in his tax reform,
he reduced the amount of medical spending
at which point it becomes deductible, which
I think is a good thing here is good thing
number two, but there's actually a much bigger
issue here.
Big Pharma shouldn't even be allowed to market
drugs in this way directly to consumers and
in a whole bunch of countries.
It's not legal for big Pharma to market drugs
directly to consumers in this way.
Direct marketing of drugs to patients is very
profitable for big Pharma.
Um, it leads to patients actually going in
and asking for a particular drug of their
doctors.
And a lot of countries don't allow this.
And in fact I know New Zealand does or at
least did allow this type of direct to consumer
pharmaceutical marketing.
But I had trouble finding other wealthy western
countries that allow these types of pharmaceutical
commercials on a math, you know, large reach,
corporate media, uh, marketing particular
drugs to individuals.
And the pharmaceutical companies will always
say we do this because we want patients to
know things are out there and ultimately their
doctor's is going to be the one to decide
is it the right thing for them?
Is it not the right thing for them?
We're not actually pushing drugs to people,
but we know that that's not the case.
We know that doctors sort of lean in the direction
of drugs that patients propose to them.
We know that in the same way doctors are influenced
by the gifts and the being wined and dined
and shuttled around on different trips by
pharmaceutical companies.
And the proof is in the reality that the companies
keep doing it right?
If pharmaceutical companies realized, Oh,
you know what?
We're spending all this money on doctors wining
and dining and giving them gifts and trips
and dinner and they're not prescribing any
more of our medications, they would immediately
stop because they're for profit companies
and they're not going to do something that's
not good for their profits.
In the same way, if pharmaceutical companies
believed or realized or noticed that when
they market drugs direct to consumers on television,
radio, wherever, that it has no effect on
the amount of prescriptions that are actually
filled.
They would immediately stop doing it because
it would be a waste of money.
They know that it works, and once again, we
were talking about this yesterday.
Lots of the ways that the US is unique aren't
good things.
We are third in the world for climate denial
behind Saudi Arabia and Indonesia among a
group of 25 countries that were surveyed.
It's not an achievement to be proud of.
We are one of the few wealthy Western countries
that allows advertising for medications on
television directly to consumers.
This is not a distinction that we should be
proud of and to be super thorough, there are
some studies which show that there is a net
benefit to society and to the economy for
advertising for antidepressants on television.
Okay, so this is complex.
I'm against these types of ads as a general
rule, but I have read some studies which say
that when you have advertising for antidepressants
on television, on the one hand, usually the
ones being advertised are the ones that have
not gone generic and that are the most profitable
ones.
So yes, you have this impact where people
see an ad for a particular antidepressant
and they go to their doctor and that's the
one that they asked for.
And we can argue that that's not necessarily
in the patient's best interest.
It'd be better if the doctor without any influence
from the patient evaluated the available medications
and decided which one was best.
But there are pure reviewed studies which
say that when you have a direct to consumer
television advertising for antidepressants,
it actually helps to get people who are depressed
on antidepressants who otherwise would not,
and that there's a measurable societal benefit
to that.
There's a measurable economic benefit.
It reduces absenteeism at work.
For example, depression is connected with
other medical conditions which can be expensive
to treat.
It reduces those by virtue of getting more
people on antidepressants.
So I think that if that's the case, if we
believe that those studies are accurate, you
can achieve a lot of that with more general
sort of nonprofit ads, which say, uh, if you
have these symptoms, there are medications,
talk to your doctor, your doctor can recommend
something that could be useful probably in
combination with psychotherapy, for example.
So you could probably get a lot of the benefit,
the societal benefit, the general benefit
that there is for people who are suffering
from depression, seeking treatment for it
without allowing individual for-profit, big
pharmaceutical companies to market the most
profitable pills that they have directly to
consumers.
But anyway, good for Trump, right?
I mean it's a small victory.
I will gladly take it and I will gladly play
praise Donald Trump for it in the middle of
what is otherwise a holy disastrous and embarrassing
presidency period.
And uh, if Trump does something again that
I agree with, I will be sure to let you know
we've got a great program for you today.
I am going to be opening up the phone lines
after the break.
I know that there are more people than ever
who are trying to get a hold of me on the
program, which is a nice, it's flattering
in many ways.
Uh, later on in the program we will answer
some audience questions including a very popular
question that comes in from a lot of people
in the audience.
Why does the David Pakman show have a disproportionately
male audience?
And there is actually a lot of interesting
data behind that, uh, will also answer some
other questions.
And then we've got a great bonus show today
as well for our members and patrons will talk
about issues of discrimination within the
Boston police force will not come as a surprise
to many people who know the city of Boston.
We will talk about what is being described
as a Pokemon region in adults who played Pokemon
as kids.
Also on the bonus show, we will talk about
the reopening of an investigation into Donald
Trump's handling of hurricanes in Puerto Rico
and the United States Virgin Islands.
All of those stories and more later on on
the bonus show in the immediate, I look forward
to hearing from folks
on
the phones, uh, right after this quick break.